alors que le balzac sinal vient d'être
votée par le parlement l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi le
conseil constitutionnel se prononcera ce
vendredi en faveur ou non de son
adoption définitive
une loi qui met en colère les anti
vaccins opposé depuis le début aux
mesures du gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron mais pas seulement les
manifestants sont have a brûlé dépasse
sa mi temps certains primo vacciner
avait la brûler leurs passes un acte
symbolique qui vise à dénoncer le
chantage des libertés et ces mesures
toujours plus restrictives qui n'en
finissent plus ce nouveau face vaccinal
prévoit d'octroyer le droit au contrôle
d'identité pour ceux qui douteraient de
l'authenticité du baas non là la carte
d'identité ça va ça va trop loin alors
bruneton passe soutenez-vous ces
français qui appellent à brûler leurs
passes
merci d'être avec nous à 20h50 on est en
direct olive olivier qu'on engage un
professeur christian perronne
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses et
françois jolivet député la république en
marche alors aujourd'hui on a vu en top
tweets surgir brûle ton pass on a agité
ou à vous montrer où on y voit certains
français brunet leurs passes pour
protester contre les mesures sanitaires
prises par le gouvernement des libyens
pourquoi vous faites ça prouve et et
vous vous vous êtes pour le boulot pour
le vote passe bien sûr
je parlerai au niveau livre
alors on va voir on va voir les images
l'ultime geste de protestation
les manifestants sont invités à brûler
symboliquement dépasse sanitaires
tous redoutent une restriction de leurs
droits et reste allergique au pass and
it
concept oxydé au monde sinon on devait
très tout ça sert d'être solidaires
[Musique]
alors olive oil parce que tu as brûlé
ton pas ce non-match à la je vais le
faire symboliquement
le poste parce que première chose que
l'on obligé de faire des passes et là je
vous lance un message moi je vous lance
un message ça c'est la flamme de la
liberté j'espère qu'on va retrouver nos
libertés pour nous et nos enfants voyez
c'est symbolique mais moi je le fais
devant vous monsieur j'ai grandi le
bon message qui est passé alors ça vient
de retenir non mais bon au niveau livre
pourquoi pour le compass bon en fait je
n'arrive pas à comprendre d'ailleurs je
vous plains moi je vous dis honnêtement
je vous plains pas ce que vous êtes en
train de défendre l'indéfendable
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe
dans notre pays et tant mieux les rayons
se vident c'est génial on nous apprend
qu'il ya au micron qui est 80 90 % moins
sévère que le reste c'est encore mieux
les pays qui sont autour de nous qui
sont en train de lever les restrictions
l'espagne qui devraient passer ça comme
une grippe l'israël nous apprend
aujourd'hui qui veulent arrêter la
quatrième dose enfin tout est en train
de se lever et vous vous continuez
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
voulez pas dire c'est que vous êtes en
train de faire impasse politique vous
allez ramené de la contrainte jusqu'au
bout et puis dans un mois ou deux je
sais pas moi je le sens venir comme ça
vous allez faire une levée des
restrictions ce qui amènera la notoriété
pour la personne que vous défendez
perpétuellement monsieur macron est
comme ça il aura une grosse remontée
dans les sondages c'est bien joué vous
êtes fort dans la communication mais on
va falloir que ça se sache et moi
j'appelle tout le monde à retrouver sa
liberté hashtag brouille tombe à soi
alors il va vous répondre à françois
jolivet non il est très calme en
toujours
il vient de signer une tribune dans le
couloir qui fait beaucoup parler son
titre l'obligation vaccinale doit être
notre cap qu'est ce que vous pensez ce
que vous dit au niveau ligue après on va
voir le professeur christian perronne
qu'on voit plus dans les médias a une
manière très très humoristique syrie le
chaton des dire à monsieur y est ce
qu'il ya un problème sur le plateau il
fait trop chaud je comprends pas ce que
vous me dites parce qu'en fait vous êtes
sur une mode et pas grand-chose à thé
gîte pour vocation c'est vrai ce qu'on
vaut pas grand chose mais on pourrait en
parler et on est là pour ça d'ailleurs
ce que ce que je voudrais simplement
dire c'est que
moi j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui que la
politique du pass sanitaire est une
bonne chose puisque ça permet de sauver
des vies j'ai le sentiment que le pass
vaccinale qui s'est construit depuis
maintenant pas de 4 à 5 mois est aussi
une bonne chose parce que ça permet en
fait on oublie toujours les gens
disaient ils peuvent faire des tests pcr
et accéder dans les locaux mais par
contre ils pouvaient tout de même
attrapé la maladie parce que je sais on
sait tous que le pass sanitaires et même
le pass vaccinale n'empêche pas d'être
contagieux donc cet effet pour protéger
les autres et moi j'en ai marre que on
reste irène des libertés à des gens
comme moi qui suis vacciné qui a
d'ailleurs attrapé le vide est
originaire ou non et qui a attrapé un
viol mais qui était vacciné et en fait
je m'aperçois qu'en fait toute la
politique est faite non protégés que
ceux qui ne le sont pas et donc avec eux
valérie petit et le maire de
fontainebleau ferry n'est que et bien on
a décidé d'écrire cela parce qu'en fait
la politique vaccinale dans notre pays
est pas nouvelle et je rappellerai
d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui assistent à
ce débat et aux téléspectateurs que ans
le 31 décembre 2017 nous avons au
parlement votait dans une majorité sans
frontières
rendu obligatoire 11 vaccin il y en
avait 3 avant huit ont été ajoutés on
n'a pas parlé d'attentes nom n'a pas dit
que ça a intenté aux libertés
individuelles
il ya ceux qui passaient sur question
peron qui est là vous voyez beaucoup
début de la pandémie dans les médias
depuis on vous voit très peu pourquoi
sale con c'est super le visuel qui m'a
interdit de plateau parce que je
dérangeais un petit peu en haut lieu
donc moi je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai honte à la france monsieur le
député je compte que vous vos collègues
les sénateurs ont voté un texte aussi
liberticide nous ne sommes plus en
démocratie
pour une maladie qui ne tue plus
000 % de mortalité chez les gens qu'on
pourrait traiter regardez les ce qui se
passe dans le monde dans le monde
l'indonésie l'inde le pakistan s'est
quasiment zéro mort ils ont contrôlé
l'épidémie tous les pays qu'ils
vaccinent en masse ces qui s'est essayée
corrompu l'europe occidentale d'amérique
du nord et l'australie qui ont des ce
vaccin n'est pas un vaccin jeudi depuis
le départ c'est un produit expérimental
qui en train d'entretenir et d'augmenter
l'épidémie je peux vous donner toutes
les cartes du monde tous les chiffres
c'est ça donc on fait peur aux gens pour
leur imposer une dictature il n'a rien à
voir avec la politique c'est new york
red bulls a dirigé été président pendant
15 ans j'ai conseillé des gouvernements
de droite et de gauche de les presser le
président de la politique vaccinale en
france j'étais vice-président de la
politique vaccinale oms j'étais reconnu
comme un des meilleurs spécialistes des
vaccins au monde et je peux vous dire
que ce qui se passe actuellement c'est
vraiment archi nul et j'ai honte pour
mon pays qu'on puisse vous allez
conduire des jeunes alors qu'on voit que
les jeunes sont en train de mourir il ya
des sportifs camille les sportifs qui
sont morts arrivé à l'open de tennis il
ya trois sportifs ils sont pas morts
heureusement mais ils pouvaient plus un
heureusement que djokovic a sauvé
l'honneur des sportifs qui n'ont pas pu
continuer la compétition il ya des
dizaines de milliers de morts dans le
monde du à ce vaccin qui n'est pas un
vaccin et ça cheuveux si on veut revenir
là dessus ça se peut le trouver donc je
dis ça suffit honte à la france il faut
se ressaisir il faut sauver nos enfants
que tous les niveaux pas qu'on donnait
des montants du but à la france ont tout
le monde alors auto nom de quoi manger
partout dans la zone
amériques
alors qu'il ya que la france qui
maintient cette politique à suivre
monsieur monsieur attendait le pad fixé
le patac sinal est adopté il ne
s'applique pas pour l'instant
ça pique
la grande
classe à partir dont il a vocation de
conseil constutionnel ces pays qui font
marche arrière moi j'écris
oui
je vous connaissais la politique qui n'a
pas comment mais vous connaissez la
politique vaccinale est assez vérité
d'israël
ces jeux sympas été plus sévère je dis
qu'aujourd'hui on m'a fait avancer et vu
ce nouveau variant ils sont en train de
perdre alors moi que vous êtes capable
de giroud pas est-ce que vous avez vu
les messages des professeurs de tel-aviv
qui sont en train d'hurler contre leur
gouverne certains professeurs oui
monsieur mathieu professeur
je sais je sais que beaucoup de vos
confrères ne sont pas d'accord avec vous
il faut que l'été ancien seigneur mais
je connais leurs techniques et les
mythes et prescription médicale avec les
docks cycle eurokin et l'ivermectine je
connais ce débat pour autant et mais
pour autant sombrer milliards savoir
aujourd'hui
si
ça ne fonctionne pas à monsieur
qui dit leur d l'inde regarde et l'asie
regarder les professeurs vous lui dites
quoi quand vous entendez mais le japon 0
bligations zéro mort à tout le monde à
l'ivermectine l'épidémie est terminée au
japon donc faut arrêter d'être ça marche
pas c'est faux c'est ce que vous dites à
ces images envoyées corrompus qui ont du
sang fait donc j'écoute après moi je
vais évidemment je suis juste une
citoyenne engagée comme vous il vous
livre ma manière on va dire
non la seule chose c'est je me demande à
qui profite le crime donc en fait on
éclate milliard de cobaye à accepter la
vaccination
donc si cyniquement un homme politique
va être élu et d'être aimé être aimé par
son peuple et par par ces sujets on va
dire ben pourquoi il décide de faire
quelque chose qui va nous empoisonner
qui va nous tuer qui ne l'a pas être
efficace dans des deux minutes c'est ça
que je ne conduis lions qui va vous
répondre tout de suite et pourquoi vous
voulez faire passer tous les gens qui
sont contre le pass d'axel pour des
complotistes on peut juste être contré
par poser sept podiums et monsieur nous
a dit que moi ça mais moi je voulais aux
régions à toute la population française
vaccinée pour qu'une maladie qui ne tue
plus à ce que géraldine est ce qu'on
peut défendre les libertés tout ça voilà
et parce que j'ai déjanté les verts se
maintiennent étonne le faire on est tous
les sens on peut laisser le choix
jacquin géraldine salaire comme à pâtir
dans mail ait quand même alors que ça
soit géraldine ça démarre toujours
quelque part la dictature
le vrai fond de jeu laissait la liberté
car moi vous allez voter et c'est mieux
que brûler alors on va pas alors bon le
brute le ton pas c'est ce que vous êtes
noir avec les gens qui brûlent leur
passion parce que je trouve intéressant
dans le mouvement brûle temps passé qui
rappelle quelque chose d'élémentaire
c'est que si ces restrictions
liberticide elles sont en place c'est
parce qu'on les accepte et donc si on
les accepte de plus par définition elles
vont sauter voyez quelque chose qui
commence à me gêner c'est que ce pass
sanitaire vaccinale qui je rappelle au
départ devait être temporaire devait
disparaître en novembre dernier il
commence à s'installer dans nos vies on
ne communique absolument pas sur une
date de fin bas si on vient à peine
d'instaurer un nouveau pass vaccinale
ont tous niqab ce qu'on ne communique
pas sur une date de fin et moi désolé
mais j'ai la flemme de me faire scanner
toute ma vie pour sortir de chez moi
pour aller prendre un café donc ce
mouvement ont fait passer ces gens là
pour des fous derrière il ya une vraie
pensée un vrai raisonnement et je pense
que c'est important de les écouter c'est
que les sur leur axe il est aujourd'hui
qui font le plus de de la maladie les
cas graves qui contamine les autres les
médias ont dit linverse ce sont les
vacciner il ya des exemples qui sortent
de partout dans le monde et met l'accent
sur des doubles ou triples d'actionner
la réalité scientifique monsieur le
professeur moi je respecte ce que vous
êtes et mais on peut avoir aussi des
points de désaccord les 130 mille morts
sont pas ont pas été inventé par les ja
pas eu 130 milles lors du comité s'est
elle est morte et on peut s'en mordre
les choses
c'est positif on leur a dit qu'on était
françois jolivet je me dis ah monsieur
livres livres que je ne comprends pas je
ne comprends pas il faut pas mélanger
liberté et il responsabilise plus de
liberté en flanc mais c'est paraît-il
responsable maison plutôt que j'étais
content marion kébili moins sévère je ne
connais pas votre métier mais quand vous
êtes dans certains éléments monsieur
quand vous êtes dans certains métiers il
ya des obligations bâtiment bien calé en
retour de woods était déjà dense et déjà
séduit
des donneurs d'ordre en bâtiment donc
plus ce qui est certain ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on n'aurait pas ce
qu'il disait que c'était violent gignac
sait pas plus violent que ce qu'on subit
monsieur et ont subi tout ça je veux
simplement mais si vous avez décidé de
suivre vous avez le droit non moi j'ai
décidé de pas tout bien alors mathieu
mathieu avec l'iut irresponsabilité et
je pense que ça marche plus a répondu
soit scientifique 500 600 milles vous
savez pourquoi des perdu 600 mille
pattes sanitaire samedi parce que les
gens ne vous font plus confiance les
gens comprennent ou marche
merci monsieur mais s'il faut pas
confiance comme vous dites nous
la majorité qui est très large et
d'ailleurs sans frontières sur le sujet
tout le monde pourra s'exprimer et tout
le monde pourra voter ce que je veux
dire c'est que les arguments que j'en
sais rien mais n'y a pas de quand même
sur les arguments que vous tenez
aujourd'hui je les ai entendus à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est vrai que
c'est les habits en lui-même
est aujourd'hui rangé
ses pains sans frontières souples et
c'est pas un scoop c'est pas le premier
professeur premiers docteurs qui dirait
qu'ils sont pas vendus cowitz et les
personnes qui sont morts d'autres choses
et qu'on a
rires avec le co vie des mois la
nature bien sûr il est vrai que j'avais
su en réanimation il y en a beaucoup
j'ai pas la culture de mathieu mathieu
de monsieur mais j'ai du bon sens
effectivement pourquoi on en est au
passé
vaccinale et on en est là parce que
justement comme vous dites on pourra
respecter vos libertés comme tu dis
guillaume genton monsieur mais respecte
et aux libertés si elle ne touchait pas
les nombreux proches vous êtes content
là on est sur bolt on passe et ltt
aujourd'hui mon mathieu qu absolument et
part ça ça te dérange pas pour une clé
mc kibben leur passe absolument cinq
jours john wheeler pas parce
qu'effectivement encore une fois ce que
vous faites et vos libertés pardon ça ne
touche pas que vous sinon ça ne
dérangera pas
mais ça a touché boxing quoi et on tu
veux on te demandent rien n'ont effectué
à tous je vous libère c'est ma manière
de vous pousser au vacciner pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois
vous faites en sorte que certaines
personnes n'ont pas accès à des soit
parce que vous remplissez les
réanimations
sepsie l'animation très complet de tous
les magazines et les remercions
4,53 dame accueille les cinq pions de
génie sur matthew le professeur question
par an seraient vaccinés qui
remplissaient ranimation alors la france
est un peu de retard et l'averse ça y
est c'est reconnu officiellement que
beaucoup de vacciner à l'hôpital que non
vaccinés dans les pics et c'est normal
et
le vaccin ne marche pas ils en gagnent
beaucoup à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens vaccinés qui sont en réanimation
mais bien sûr
d'être en format dvd genre animation
sont des réservations en france en train
de venir sans augmente c'est pas les
chiffres de l'ong la
finition messieurs s'il vous plaît la
définition d'un vaccin c'est quoi dans
le dico s'est créé une immunité dont
sont extraits du messie je vais vous
dire quelque chose de différent s'il
vous plaît de seconde le discours serait
différent dans 100% de la tête des gens
à partir du moment si vous étiez
vaccinez vous pouviez pas attrapé le
virus vous pouviez pas le transmettre et
vous pouviez pas leur en rien je peux
vous jurer monsieur que j'aurai à
nouveau livre haut niveau